[Musik]
die berliner sind wieder draußen
probieren wie es sich lebt nachdem
lockdown im land und ja manches fühlt
sich fast an wie früher
bevor die welt stillstand wegen corona
wochen lang leben geschäfte gastronomie
und spielplätze geschlossen jetzt kehrt
ein bisschen alltag in die hauptstadt
zurück und die meisten sind darüber
erleichtert
allerdings müssen die berliner jetzt
selbst dafür sorgen dass der schutz
ihrer mitmenschen gewahrt bleibt ob das
funktioniert hin und her geht die
meinung der deutschen zu viel vorsicht
oder zu wenig die lockerungen zu früh
oder zu spät
es ist eine probe für den zusammenhalt
der gesellschaft
der gesellschaft schon sehr hoch ein und
denke dass auch viele menschen sich
bewusst sind dass sich auch die träger
teilen können und da auch solidarisch
miteinander umgehen dass alle
tatsächlich mit spielen beim schutz
gegen das virus dieses gefühl teilt hier
in berlin neukölln nicht jeder vor allem
ältere machen sich sorgen
krachen lassen ausreichend abstand waren
in diesem park in prenzlauer berg halten
sich die meisten daran was kann man tun
was sollte man lassen dass selbst zu
entscheiden fällt offenbar schwer eine
pseudo solidarität dass du dich quasi
schnell anpassen kannst wenn du jetzt
beobachtet wirst in berlin kreuzberg
geht es zwangloser zu für manche ist die
pandemie anscheinend wieder vorbei
andere zweifeln ob es sie überhaupt gibt
öffentlich zugeben will das aber niemand
der markt der meinungen ist
unübersichtlich es ist halt ein
wissenschaftliches thema und das ist
natürlich schwierig für menschen die
erst mal nur sich gar nicht so täglich
mit diesen fakten oder wie auch immer
auseinander setzen einen schritt
aufeinander zu zu machen
weil die einen geben sich als die super
experten aus und die anderen ländern
eher aus ihrer eigenen emotionalen
wahrnehmung wie umgehen mit der korona
pandemie auch die berliner ringen mit
dieser frage und dieser ältere herr
besinnt sich auf ganz eigene weise
[Musik]